Salve youtubers Benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione prima di iniziarla come al
solito vorrei consegnare un paio di
canali uno è quello di nirchio dei
ragazzi che fanno video molto molto
divertenti probabilmente li avrete visti
per video come quelli della maturità o
quelli dell'università che sono stati
condivisi parecchio su Facebook
iscrivetevi perché ne vale la pena ho
fatto anche una particina nel loro
ultimo video di Bloopers il secondo
canale che pubblicizzo è quello del blog
delle classifiche Il blog delle
classifiche è un progetto abbastanza
interessante dove ogni tot di tempo eh
questo canale posta un video dove c'è
dove la community cioè noi quelli che
guardano il video possono votare quello
che c'è nel video cioè eh Un giorno c'è
chi è il miglior Joker di tutti i film
di Batman Hit leger o Jack Nicholson e
voi potete votare per esempio detto
questo iniziamo oggi recensisco un film
che mi avete consigliato a voi bestiacce
Maledette comodo versus cobra Premetto
che io sono un amante dei Monster Movie
film come rodan il mostro alato
L'invasione degli astromostri gli eredi
di King Kong e via dicendo ma c'è una
differenza tra questo genere di Monster
Movie e questo genere di Monster Movie
la differenza sta nel fatto che i
Monster Movie asiatici sono strettamente
legati alla cultura asiatica Quindi
nonostante siano film di fantascienza
hanno un senso i film americani no
neanche un po' perché
comodo non è una creatura leggendaria
della della Cultura e dei costumi
americana Spero comodo
è una schifezza una schifezza di
creatura quando io ho letto comodo
versus cobra Vabbè il cobra è il cobra
ma il comodo è soltanto una lucertola
Gigante ma poi lo sappiamo che quando
c'è un prodotto americano con un vs in
mezzo al titolo non promette nulla di
buono lo sappiamo ormai è inutile
illuderci il film in sé è una noia
colossale cioè le uniche scene veramente
Trash da poter essere recensite sonoo
quelle d'azione quindi vedrete
Praticamente soltanto questo nella
recensione numero 5 partiamo malissimo
io faccio partire il film sono lì che
aspetto per vedere cosa mi propina
questo putridume quando ad un certo
punto compare Lui proprio
lui lo avete riconosciuto qualcuno lo ha
riconosciuto è il tizio di megap piragna
Cioè questo attore è affamato di film
trash ma proprio trash trash ma
veramente questo attore è così disperato
Da dover fare una comparsata di 5 minuti
in qualsiasi film pattume che esista
sulla faccia della terra non giudico gli
stili di vita ma che schifo
Però numero 4 comodo versus cobra
ora se tu mi fai un film chiamato comodo
versus cobra ma proprio
teoricamente dovrebbe esserci almeno un
comodo e almeno un cobra che si
scontrano Secondo voi eh in un'ora e
mezza di film quante volte si sono
scontrati il comodo e il
cobra Chi ha risposto si scontrano una
volta sola alla fine del film per 30
secondi ha indovinato voglio dire voglio
del trash guardo un film trash perché
voglio trash non me ne frega niente di
sapere i flashback della storia i
retroscena di come si è sviluppato il
cioè teoricamente una rispostina a
qualche domanda me la dai ma non per
un'ora intera voglio azione voglio
sparatorie
forse numero tre muzzle flashes Qualcuno
sa cosa sono i muzzle flashes i muzzle
flashes sono le fiammate che escono
fuori dalla pistola quando si spara
quanto cavolo è difficile mettere i
muzzle flashes nella pistola No perché
nel vog del mio secondo canale io ho
detto che avrei postato piccolissimi
filmati di pochi secondi con degli
effetti speciali giusto per prova Allora
da poco ho fatto una piccolissima
sparatoria con el spons il mio amico
giusto Cioè le l' inquadrature facevano
schifo però ho ho l'ho fatto giusto per
mettere il mazzel flash e i colpi contro
il muro il fumo eccetera mi è venuto
così così cioè un po' amatoriale ma mi è
venuto
bene
merda quando poi ho visto le sparatorie
di comodo versus cobra ho detto porca
miseria posso vendere il mio film se io
vado dal produttore di questa porcheria
sicuramente il mio cortometraggio lo
compra a milioni di dollari guardate e
Commentate
voi ma non c'è solo quello eh Ce ne sono
altri C loro li hanno sminchiati tutti
quanti muzzle flashes da farli Bianchi a
farli mobili a farli che si
ingrandiscono e si riducono e compaiono
dal nulla ma quando vanno a casa Queste
persone poi hanno il coraggio di dire
Sono un tecnico degli effetti speciali
No perché se lo facessero davvero Io
prenderei quei pollici e glieli ficchi
negli
occhi numero due Ma quanti cavolo di
colpi ha una pistola e io non sono un
esperto di armi da fuoco però sai tra
videogiochi film e telefilm più o meno
riesco a capire che se spari 400.000
colpi con una pistola c'è qualcosa che
non va ma proprio leggermente qualcosa
che non va ma dico io almeno quello
guardate questa scena Provate a contare
Voi quanti cavolo di colpi sparano le
pistole Oh my God
Ah cioè voi pensate il connubio colpi
infiniti nella pistola e muzzle flashers
orribili pensate che cacchio di film è
questo i mazzel flash sono effetti
speciali E va bene o li sai fare o non
li sai fare ma i colpi della pistola no
i colpi della pistola sono una cosa che
si scrive nel copione lo devi scrivere
Scrivi adesso prendo la pistola e sparo
bam bam bam tre colpi oppure bam bam bam
bam una raffica di cinque di sei poi
carico perché nel film non si vede mai
mai caricare l'arma mai e dall'inizio
del film alla fine hanno sempre la
stessa pistola Chi ha visto il film può
confermarlo e ripeto se noi uniamo
muzzle flashes orribili e colpi infiniti
cosa vien
fuori numero uno le sparatorie Come ho
detto prima nella posizione numero uno
ci sono tutte le scene virgolette
sarcastiche d'azione Sapete qual è il
problema ve lo spiego quando tu fai una
scena d'azione con una cosa in computer
grafica e le persone sono vere le
persone quando devono sparare a questa
cosa mentre girano non la vedono perché
non c'è ancora viene messa in
postproduzione ma nei film con bravi
registi questo non è un problema perché
vengono messi dei segnalatori Oppure
delle persone con dei bastoni che poi
vengono tolte al computer e vengono
posizionate nel posto in cui ci dovrebbe
essere il mostro l'alieno o quel che è
secondo voi hanno fatto così anche
qui sicuramente infatti possiamo vedere
in questa scena che quello che dovrebbe
sparare al Cobra in realtà Mira da
tutt'altra parte da tutt'altra parte
perché il cobra è abbassato e lui
comunque spara dov'era prima il cobra
perché non non lo vede perché ancora non
c'è nella scena in cui lui ha girato e
di queste scene è pieno il film pieno Ma
la cosa ancora peggiore di questa è la
sparatoria in sé Guardate che poi
commentiamo No questa scena m'ha fatto
veramente morire dalle risate cioè
Guardate come lui se ne frega altamente
di come sta sparando a cosa sta sparando
non gliene frega nulla scappate Scappate
di qua Sì Sì adesso arrivo anch'io
adesso arrivo ch non vi
preoccupate è una bella giornata Però
oggi eh Scusate non ho resistito è
ridicolo ridicolo noioso e ridicolo e
noioso Ma
scusate il cobra non è un animale da
deserto o comunque da posto molto molto
caldo no perché qui è è un'isola
deserta tropicale e il cobra si nasconde
anche in acqua No perché ci sono tante
di quelle domande che questo cazzo di
film non ha risposto Non della storia
non me ne frega niente domande
concettuali perché le pistone hanno
colpi infiniti perché non riesce a fare
i muzzle flashes perché c'è un cobra che
va sott'acqua perché questi film li
vendono e li danno anche in televisione
perché tutti quelli che hanno visto il
film si sono Suicidati alla fine perché
finisci con un cavolo di cliffhanger
Anche qui tutti i film squallidi con il
cliffhanger
ah
ridatemi megga piragna Vi prego